né en 1960 à daloa
déjà tout petit tout le monde trouvait
que j'avais des capacités
j'avais des les capacités de leadership
est pour ça que le m me confier des
responsabilités telle que relevée le nom
des bavards en place corriger des
devoirs et tout ça je le fais avec
passion
je n'avais pas peur j'étais bien à
l'école
j'étais aimé
parmi tous les temps au tour tous mes
amis à l'école annoncée pour celle des
années plus tard et non pas moi qui
venait lui de rentrer définitivement de
france trouvait que j'avais des
capacités de leadership par le second
devient convaincu mes parents d'emma
menées en france et que j'avais un
potentiel que je voulais bien développée
en france il paraît que c'est en france
qu'on devient plus intelligent moi je ne
sais pas mais je suis parti
alors en france je m'inscris à l'école
d'infirmière à asnières dans le 92e mais
je sentais qu'il y avait quelque chose
qui me manquait c'était pas trop la
france qu'il me fallait que je voulais
pas rester en france
alors j'avais le choix de tout un pays
j'avais le canada grand bil'in j'avais
la suisse pas trop loin en europe
j'avais les états unis pays de
possibilités malheureusement et
heureusement c'est trois pays ne l'ont
pas acceptée
et voilà le destin qui décide autrement
je me retrouve alors la norvège juste
une petite idée des géographies c'est un
pays qui se trouve à scandinavie avec 5
millions d'habitants à peine c'est une
monarchie on a un mois qui s'appelle le
roy raz la capitale c'est oslo les
ressources se repaissent la pêche le
pétrole et le gaz
le bois est l'énergie hydraulique et
l'agriculture donne c'est le nom de gien
que j'ai parle voilà la population jeudi
a dit comment
qui l'aurait cru en moi petite fille née
dans le fin fond des dalots la has à
gorée pas
pouvait introduit un produit
traditionnel legname abuja dans un
marché aussi fermé
il faut coin on sait qu'on perd il faut
pas se faire des limites
ou en tout cas plus fort
c'est même le nom mais quand je vois
notre premier ministre contre un exemple
et quand elle parle de diversité
d'innovation des valeurs dans la
communauté
c'est aussi avec beaucoup d'humilité que
j'aurais c'est vrai ici le prix de la
même huile de meilleur entrepreneur de
l'année en 2015 des mains de notre danse
rituelle son excellence même du score de
magnus de la cuisine merci de la cuisine
à l'industrie c'était dur mais comme l a
fait c'est de ma cuisine
fin mai des casseroles
exactement comme maman grand maman tout
le monde ici a eu le lien makoun j à la
maison comment nos mamans fait ça avec
les deux mains et moi j'avais quelques
casseroles que j'aime mélanger jusqu'à
ce que je trouvais jusqu'à ce que je
trouve le bout qui correspondait à mon
marché alors j'ai fait une petite
production que j'ai appris je suis sorti
allez voir le restaurant les coffee
shops de du quartier et la première dame
que j'ai rencontrés qui dirigeait un
café café bar je lui donne la bouteille
elle goûte elle sait où elle goûte
elle rougit médias mais j'aime
j'aime mais et mes clients est ce qu'ils
vont aimer ce que vous allez pas madame
mettez-vous devant ma porte fait de la
promo fait goûter à mes clients qui
aimante et on va voir on va voir la
réaction
alors je mets mais là le premier jour
j'ai fait la dégustation deuxième jour
troisième jour et quand je ne venais pas
la dame elle m'appelle le troisième jour
puisque j'étais en train de faire là
début elle m'appelle et me dit mais il
ya des gens qui viennent à la maison ici
dans le café ici et qui demande après
vous ou est ce que vous êtes et ce que
vous vous devez de la production vous
pouvez emmener débouté seydoux l'a alors
je me dépêche je prends moins 45 à 50
buts et je vais dans le coffee shop
elle place le lendemain je viens pouvoir
pour entamer un feedback
il reste cinq à dix bouteilles qu'il
doit à leurs yeux de ma mère mais ce que
vous pouvez me recommander à quelqu'un
d'autre et c'est comme ça de ces partis
premier riche en deuxième
elle est commandée la même chose la même
réaction le deuxième super match et
j'avais trouvé des galas qui étaient là
j'ai fait la même chose
et eux ils ont pris tout de suite est-ce
que vous en avez vous apporté elle a
ajouté je me disais un roi mais c'est
bien mais comment je vais fait j'avais
peur je savais que j'avais créé un
marché
mais quand même pas un poubelle a
provisionné ce marché les clients
étaient là
il voulait avoir le nez makudi madame
était de la cuisine en train de faire
les petites bouteilles j'avais peur
mais quelquefois il fait pas se reposer
sur ça parce que c'est cette petite
voilà qui nous parle
pourquoi tu peux faire ça comment tu
peux arriver c'est trop difficile
je suis allé à moteur ça c'est là où il
faut le commander 100 français le ski et
jean ping
vous comptez c'est le ski la conférence
qui suis monté et quand je suis descendu
tout était parti
alors j'ai commencé à faire mes
recherches j'ai appelé les industries
des endroits où on faisait des
productions de jus et tout et tout pour
me fait produire reçu de gens j'aime
oniam a conduit personne ne savait en
norvège le jem ne pousse pas en norvège
rim aurait refusé et c'est un petit
producteur de jus saisonniers qui m'a
acceptée lançant à sa ligne de
production
et c'est là que j'ai voulu et comme la
demande augmentait il fallait encore
sorti aller dans une autre production
qui est un peu plus grande
de fil en aiguille je suis partie de
cette petite production jusqu'à la
grande production et je n'avais pas
d'âge et donc je me suis je me suis
adressé à ma commune demandez un peu
avec un peu d'argent avec un peu de
financement pour pouvoir augmenter ma
production
c'est comme ça que c'est parti
mais aussi dans la production comme on
dit en norvégien la main de l'impact
donc j'avais la main à la pâte et voilà
je sais pas si ça va marcher bah c'est
comme ça que c'est aller dans une grande
production
et moi je dis j'appartiens à deux pays
mais pays de naissance qui la côte
d'ivoire est le pays qui m'a accueilli
la mauvaise il maquille avec les grands
les bras ouverts
alors j'ai cherché un point de rencontre
comment faire bénéficier le pays qui m'a
accueilli et mon pays de naissance et a
même pas comment aider la population ici
en côte d'ivoire puisque le norvégien
l'heure les gens j'aime ils poussent ici
non il fallait voir comment
approvisionner en produits bruts alors
j'ai crié j'ai réuni les femmes de mon
village pour créer un petit projet
pilote peut planter le juge jean alain
boumsong en norvégien en norvège mais en
anglais je vais le dire c'est médine way
out of africa
merci annonce est pas un c'est pressé
par magic c'est pas du mal à montage
moi j'ai des petites recommandations
comment il faut prendre des risques dans
nos régions ne savait pas le cas makoun
n'avaient jamais goûté en tout cas
beaucoup ne connaissaient pas sauf ceux
qui ont voyagé il faut avoir une bonne
morale de temps dit il faut bien
travailler il faut travailler il faut
bien
ensuite il faut avoir la culture du
résultat
il faut pas travailler comme ça il faut
en voir dans le deux semaines dans trois
semaines dans un mois dans toi moi quel
résultat
je dois obtenir c'est à partir de là
vous faites des petits buts conflit la
qualité parce qu'aujourd'hui les gens
ils savent que
et tellement de produits c'est le marché
il faut pas leur offrir n'importe quoi
il faut la qualité font de miser sur la
qualité
alors je me dis qu'il peut être
entrepreneur pour être entrepreneur il
faut suivre sa passion parce que
l'argent ne vient pas tout de suite
l'argent viendra après si c'est par
votre patience vous allez être découragé
il faut pas sauter les étapes
il faut suivre les étapes à toute
personne qui était menacée qui a
l'audace et qui n'a pas peur des risques
et toute personne qui a des idées
innovatrices
c'est ça aussi et toute personne qui est
capable de prendre le taureau par les
cornes et passer de l'ordinaire à
l'extraordinaire parce que dans la
société à 95% et la clé à 5%
mais les 5% il ya la place le tunnel
vers là où il ya 95%
il faut l'être la wii à 5% la population
il ya de place la balle ces personnes là
moi je trouve que ces seules ces
personnes qui peuvent attirer une
richesse innovatrices
je voulais merci merci de m'avoir écouté